this is Startalk I am your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and for this Startalk
live we are going to explore
transgendered visibility today and I've
got Natalia Regan here hello Natalia
she's one of our star talk all-stars
and she's a anthropologist who thought
deeply about that and Chuck yeah hey
buddy
yeah how are you so transgendered
visibility day first of all who declares
these days that's okay so the
transgender community did not have a day
celebrating those that had worked so
hard in the past to become visible so in
2009 they created it's actually
transgender day of visibility and so
basically around for eight years okay
it's finally I mean obviously with the
internet with Twitter and with Facebook
and all these things it's getting more
and more steam I mean people there we're
talking more about these issues and of
course it regime that's a very dated
source of energy poll it's coming back
guys coming back it is thermonuclear
feel dated solar power
okay so just will be taking inquiries
from Patti's book live but if you just
set the stage here there are people
above just up whatever age who were just
perplexed by this exactly and people now
describing not gender being male or
female but that there's a special on
binary yeah so human medically in terms
of your sexual preference has every
dimension answer and to be clear gender
and sexuality are two totally different
things and gender and and sex are two
totally different things gender is
generally it's a social construct it's
in the brain sex is what's going down
below the waist which you can vary there
are people that have are intersex
individuals that have differences no
longer called hermaphrodites
yeah it's now generally intersex there's
no perfect but there's also varying
versions of what that can be but as far
as transgender individuals they
basically wanted to celebrate people in
the past that had fought for visibility
but to be clear gender again in the head
sex below the belt cisgender which is
what somebody that identifies
there what's going on in their brain
matches what's going down downstairs
typically like system versus gender
transgender is where that does not fit
so if your doesn't match is a match and
so it just doesn't match exactly well
it's yeah in that again that's what
we're changing our way of looking at it
it's not no longer a problem it's
actually being celebrated you're not
you're not a mistake you know you are
you're just as good as everybody else
there's also people that identify as
non-binary or genderqueer which are
those that don't feel like they fit in a
traditional male female gender occurred
well they can be either at a different
time okay - yeah exactly
gender fluid and that's the thing is
gender people have even identified a
certain genders at certain parts of
different parts of their life you know
it's fluid has a fishel physics
definition and it is a substance that
takes the shape of its container Wow so
air is a fluid as is a liquid in that
context fluid there's a different
container here I'll do that right here
yeah right sometimes for different at
different points of our life right so we
get our questions coming in yeah my
names are already coming in and I
actually left one up because this was
the very first question and before we
take any questions the reason why we do
this is so that we can tell you guys
that for everything that you want to
find Startalk there's a place to go
called Startalk all-access dot-com and
that's where we have things that are
original content that you can't find
anywhere else we have extended content
that we had to cut and so we put it
there in full form it is all commercial
free and you can also find video of the
podcast itself that you normally can
only find in audio form all of that is
born Startalk all-access comm and if you
subscribe within this week we will be
revealing for only one day at the end of
this weekend nude pictures of Neil
deGrasse Tyson so please make sure you
go make sure you go and subscribe to
Startalk all-access comm will be able to
see your nude picture Neil deGrasse
Tyson at least wait till I get my
six-pack
all right let's say our first question
and the first question comes from Eric
theory and Eric says that please answer
how does gender identity and sexual
orientation work in the brain why can
two siblings have so much in common and
one prefers their own sex and the other
prefers the opposite Thanks it's like
the million dollar question because
there isn't I think a clear-cut answer
at this point how you know some people
say that it's a choice and know it oh we
hear in your library so there isn't I I
personally do not know the answer to
that question because I don't think
there is an answer of exactly the
mechanism of how one chooses you at
you're absolutely right the reason why
you don't know the answer to that
question is because we haven't found
that yeah question if we had we even
though we are looking at whether or not
there is a genetic link to your gender
your sexuality and your preferences but
even sexuality like to be fair and to be
clear it is on a spectrum and people are
fluid you know people prefer certain
things at different times in their life
for whatever reason I bring up a
morality question suppose we learned
there's a part of the brain that
generates sexual preference okay and
there are societal pressures that you
should be one way and not another and
then someone says I can go in and
operate and weakside that well it's like
those camp phase two have to try or a
lot I think they still happen I'll try
to change you know kids orientation
exactly yeah and but yeah I miss a moral
question I also think that it means
society is in denial of who you actually
are
then says but we can fix that that
that's that's a peculiar world it is and
I feel like humans are interesting as
far as animals as a species we are the
only animal that really kind of puts a
sort of moral you know a layer on top of
sex and sexual sexual orientation you
know you don't see a chimpanzee
struggling like oh god I don't know
should I should I ask Steve out I know
I'm a male but I you know you don't see
that same sort of dogs don't have that
problem either they help whatever
anything
ouch my leg Jim Beverly what else you
got what I apologize for all of that um
I'm having trouble I got one here are
the instances all their England
switching during development later in
life this is cold primo is drawn from
Facebook are the instances of
brain-switching during development later
in life which is something you're born
with as far as I mean so one of the
things that happened a lot in the past
was like say for instance if you were
dealing with a if you had a child that
was intersex a lot of times parents
would might choose at the time of birth
what sex to a you know what gender you
would marry or surgically surgically and
sometimes they make mistakes and so that
child is left to grow up in a in a body
that does not match the brain so the
mistake means they left them with with
plumbing that is different from a brain
brains expectation of the plumbing
should be something that they're doing
now is it waiting waiting until the
child can choose what feels right age is
that because we saw pictures of someone
who was like 11 right who was born male
but it's expressing female in middle
school do we know enough about our
gender identity by then I think they can
say like the tween ages is when they're
really starting to kind of wait between
maybe that's sort of that's sort of
solid you know choices but as far as
making sort of a gender reassignment or
any sort of surgical I think they're
waiting and not doing at that age that's
that's very young so men are just
another question Malcolm Oliver Mar
Marfan not golfin Martha we got from
Malcolm so are the brains of men and
women wired differently and and have we
found this to be true also for
transgender individuals it's the extent
to which we know it's in the brain maybe
we can't figure out where does what it's
doing but we can show that it's
different slightly right that that's a
base level of information so males and
females as far as sex goes I are far
more similar than then dissimilar okay
out there like we we want the same
things
oftentimes we strive for the same thing
because except you guys are often left
disappointed and we're not
let go all right so sorry there's things
that affect our you know behavior
sometimes like like you know different
hormones and if someone has more
estrogen or more testosterone and their
body they're going to behave differently
but I don't think there's been actual
studies about the hard wiring of
transgender individuals versus those
that are not studied other primates do
you see any gender spectrum behavior
another Brunell I mean Bona Beauchamp
Cindy's right that see that's what we
talked about a little bit which is
really interesting bonobos are funny
because they're all about having lots of
sex and they're also female dominant we
talk about animal okay I'm sorry
that's how they defuse tension like say
for instance there's a piece on the
fruit on the ground like you know if we
have to go we want to choose who gets
out his fruit there would be lovemaking
and then we'd probably forget that there
was fruit there to begin with
where is very other moments wingless
creatures ever quite settle disputes I'm
making I'll make love for it let's love
it out sorry fight love it out
come on let's do it
but but but what we should say one of
the things that makes bonobos different
from other cousins chimpanzees female
dominant social group the females are in
charge which means hey maybe if we let a
woman be in charge of the United to you
I don't know my daddy you if the answer
to conflict resolution is let's make
love we would give over the power
commands okay I'm just letting you know
it might be hugs we got it you know and
you can social no no no that's not the
right joke the right joke is if you let
a woman be President she'll be tweeting
all day about everything she feels about
haha that I think we have a woman
president guys right no let's let's go
another one so Tony Allen is their
particular age when someone realizes
their orientation is there an average
age where you can then say pretty much
you know where you're coming from and
where you're going by I mean I think it
has a lot to do with just individuals
but I think a lot of people I mean I my
orientation I'm assuming they mean
sexual orientation yeah
not how they feel is gender wise
yes people talk about it it's early a
like five four or five you know I don't
know I have several things yeah you tell
me like I was four years old nine knew
for a fact you know like we're years old
four years old they were like and I said
to a friend of mine I'm like how did you
know that you haven't you know you were
gay when you were four and he said let
me ask you this when you were four
did you like women and I was like you
know I absolutely did I knew I knew then
he was like it's exactly you didn't know
what you were that's because you
were too busy loving science I know I'll
say this and I'll wrap it up real quick
back when I was eight I thought I was
gay because I actually thought I was
attracted to women at one point I was
like oh my god that means I didn't
realize that there was a spectrum you
know I mean and now that visibility and
now that we're seeing but you know very
courageous people people coming out and
and so showing that there are
alternatives and that this is not a
spectrum and you know it's okay at state
whenever you are it's okay you're fine
if you fall in that spectrum good for
you we have a facebook live viewer
called Albert Einstein who says nice
shirt
Chuck a little narcissistic don't you
think there you go buddy all right we
got we got to wrap it up this is quick
quick which is a quick one yeah fast but
a transgender day of visibility that's
new to me even though it's been around
eight years thank you to our many foxes
and you know all the activists out there
follow them on Twitter right right
excellent thanks for that suggestion
so Natalia Reagan thanks Brett thanks
for have beat but we're doing this and
Chuck always good to have you here we
got to sign out on Facebook live they
give us like 10 minutes or at most for
this and so yeah we will find us in the
universe and on Startalk all-access calm
you got it
start talking signing out